[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
good job weird seven copies smack asana
but but how how has your comic-con
experience been so far highlight best
part for me the best part so far
was almost crashing to Justice League
photo shoot but then Jason Momoa was so
big I was like hey under colleague like
let's talk about they should be you
should see that arrow coming around and
you run and you core the unity for
yourself well worthy worthy og yes
we are on Facebook live yeah they've
seen much worse things I'm telling you
don't talk about the speculation is who
is going to be this easy fix big bad do
you guys know what can you tell us
everybody likes and dreams from the
diverse I can tell you that you can't
talk about what we're learning well
Steven are we going to see more of
Oliver's struggle with fatherhood yeah
cool what else can you tell me I mean
you know William is not a he's not a
baby he's he's like we played in the
show is twelve years old he's in sixth
grade and it's it's very interesting to
see Oliver as a dad because William is
not totally digging it yet and he's
going through some stuff so stuff
what am I supposed to say you're all
dead and I can't talk about it
they're all dead confirmed Emily is
there just to be any progress in like
you in the workplace next season what
kind of storyline are we gonna get there
assuming that you are alive women in the
workplace are equal wages 71% right
there I think listening he's a job she
needs to be employed I think that she's
she's probably getting I mean she sees
these guys every day and I think she's
getting you know not not bored but um I
think she just she needs to show you
some income and some some probably
different social experiences with
different people so hopefully we get to
see her you know not so much in the
helix area maybe not going down the
rabbit hole but maybe you know working
with Curtis yeah yeah they're both in
purgatory just working together yeah
yeah it's a fun job it's tough it's a
lot of work really well echo Curtis his
vigilante Ness has cost him his
relationship it seems are we going to
see him they're fighting for that next
season I you know I like to hope that if
Curtis did come back that he would
definitely fight to get Paul back if he
comes back you know because I think that
hey I think you know he loves Paul in
either way you know I think it'd be nice
to see over here we're very long
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Oliver Felicity have been on a long
journey kind of back to each other
what could we see happen next season in
olicity terms I got a really great
question from Twitter by the way two
truths and a lie
about Oliver and Felicity's relationship
Maxine oh my god I did two truths in one
line at a con in Nashville a couple
weeks ago and I caught a rash so I gonna
pass they're getting married they're
never getting married okay well what I
mean you gotta tease me something about
next season though besides everybody
being dead for you are we gonna see any
kind of redemption for earth through
Laurel well we did get a look at the
black canary suit so what was it like
trying that on and kind of getting
fitted for that notice he doesn't mind
me be in a trailer just it was surreal
it was one of the most empowering and
surreal moments not only on the show but
I think I've had like ever I cried I had
a moment to myself and I was like I took
a breath and it was like this is real
and this is a big responsibility and
you're gonna be a hero to some kids and
like let's do this I just like it pumped
me up
you had your I'm a superhero moment I
love that know James Bamford gave her
the staff that she uses for a weapon and
every time we'd hang out and Juliana's
turning the staff practicing and working
on it like yeah she's come a long way
it's tough when you're just trying to
just talk about poor - to her and she's
just twirler that stuff
love talking board let's see what she
had it before a Carbonaro
[Laughter]